chief washington correspondent major
garrett joins us now major good morning
to you and
happy new year always good to see you
major where to begin
let's start with that phone call it's
another jaw-dropping moment from the
president but you know what i think he
likes these jaw-dropping moments
but what what is the end game here gail
the endgame is
patently and dangerously obvious
the president wants to exert whatever
fleeting
power and pressure he still has within
the confines of the white house
in any direction he can apply it to
change the outcome of this election
that is clear the president's motives
are clear
he wants to stay in power and he wants
to use whatever tools he can find
whether it's suggesting criminal
prosecution of secretaries of state like
brad raffensberger who won't do what he
tells him to do
find me a precise number of votes to
overturn the election
in one swing state or meeting with led
state legislatures from michigan or
trying to talk to the people in
pennsylvania
to overturn the election that he lost
the president cannot cope with the fact
that he lost this election whether or
not he believes he wanted or not is
immaterial
that belief does not comport with
reality but he is abusing and using
power
to overturn something he can't cope with
right the constitution doesn't create
space for that in our republic and
republicans who watch this
and stand idly by will be participating
in the weakening of that republic and
the constitution that protects us from
these kinds of abuses or attempted
abuses of power
yeah that leads me to the next question
because i i get it major i know what the
motives are
but the numbers simply aren't there and
that's why i wonder why he keeps
continuing to try to do this
it's baseless it's been proven wrong
time and time again yet he continues
but let's talk about the republicans
kudos to brad reference burger though
who seemed to fact check the president
in real time
when he was on the phone call he did not
bend but what are the republicans are
saying about this we have some that are
going along with the president
but there are many others that just say
this is not right what happens
i said on this program about two weeks
ago that if this continued you could be
watching the pulling apart the breaking
up
of the republican party as this country
has come to know it i believe that
process has only accelerated
in the last four days republicans have a
choice to make
do they believe in the constitution do
they believe in federalism
federalism means states run the
elections as the constitution
stipulates and do you believe in facts
and you do do you believe in verifiable
elections conducted with the most
transparency
ever which is what this election was or
do you believe
in the personification of a republican
party under one person and one person
only
donald trump do you believe in grievance
do you believe in conspiracy theories
do you believe in baseless allegations
that cannot stand up in court
if you do then you're part of that new
republican party and it's dividing
before our very eyes
yeah and how do you think it's going to
affect the race in georgia major the
president's going there tonight so was
joe biden
on one hand he says it's fraudulent you
know that there's corruption
on the other hand he's saying hey
everybody vote right
everyone go out and vote because
everything is at stake except this
election is corrupted in the
in the beginning i mean the mixed
message there is so clear and so obvious
and so contorted
i've talked to many republicans who are
down there they're nervous about the
outcome of this election they still
think that there is a net
favorite republicans could eat these out
but they know what the president has
deprived them of
a clear and consistent message re-elect
the republicans be a check on
incoming joe biden president trump
hasn't allowed that to happen which
makes this far more complicated than it
should have been for republicans
major i know we got to go but does the
president face any legal consequences
because he was clearly putting pressure
and
clearly it seemed to be abusing his
power it's close but probably not just
because it's a hard case to prove in
court
all right major garrett thank you very
much